بنجاح تمت عمليه عسكريه شماليه سوريا
والعراق تحت اسم المخلب السيف هكذا تقول
تركيا ردا على تفجير اجابه الاستقلال في
اسطنبول الاسبوع الماضي تتحدث انقره عن
تدمير نحو 90 هدفا تابعا لمواصفاتها
بالتنظيمه الارهابيه في اشاره الى قوه حزب
العمال الكردستاني والقوات الموليه له وفي
التفاصيل اشاره وزاره الدفاع التركيه الى
تنفيذ مقاتلات تركيه سلسله من الغابه على
مواقع عسكريه شمال شرقي سوريا وفي شمال
العراق واشارت مصادر اعلاميه الى ان
الاهداف مواقع عسكريه لما تعرفوا بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه في كل من تل رفعت
وعندنا في حلب وشمال عين عيسى في في الرقه
ومناطق في الحسكه وعين العرب كوباني على
الحدود السوريه
بينما نقلت رويترز عن متحدث باسم ما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه التي تشكل وحدته
حمايه الشعب الكرديها الفقري
طائره تركيه قصفت قريتين ماهولتين
بالنازحين في شمال سوريا اما وكاله
الانباء السوريه الرسميه فتحدثت عن مقتل
اعاده من الجنود يترهجمه تركيا قالت انها
استهدفت مواقع في ريفي حلب والحسكه
جغرافيا الهجمات التركيه طالت ايضا وفق
تصريحات لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مناطق
سنجار وكركوكس وقنديل واسوس شماليه العراق
بينما تحدثت وسائل اعلام سوريا عن قصف
القوه الكريه برجمه الصواريخ محيطه معبر
باب السلامه على الحدود التركيه بالقرب من
مدينه اعزاز بريف حلب اما وكاله الانضول
التركيه للانباء فافادت بوقوع اصابه جراه
هجوم صاروخين على منطقه قرب بوابه حدوديه
في اقليم كنيسه تركيه للحدود مع سوريا
تطورات الميدانيه تاتي بينما وعدت ما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه بالرد على الضربه
الجويه التي شالتها تركيا على مواقعها
[موسيقى]